Hey, God, sorry, I didn't see you there. You got me off guard, I was just, um, I just really missed Sean and Jason right now. Feeling real, feeling real lonely out here in this cold open, I'm on my own. Oh my God, I promised myself I would cry. Not wouldn't cry, then I would cry, and I can't do it. Gosh dang it, alright, it's an all new smartness. Smart. Smart.
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
Smart. Smart. Bless. Hi y'all. Hi y'all. Good evening. Hi, good evening. Very late. This is a very, very unusual smartness after dark.
This is smartness after dark. Yeah, I mean, should we take a piece of clothing off maybe. Oh, let's see how it goes. I mean, doesn't that what usually happens after dark in my house? Okay, everyone's topless after six. No kidding. Am I the only one of my pajamas
other than the baseball hat? No, I'm in my pajamas, but that doesn't change anything from our daytime recording. No, no, no, no, no. But JB, what's the earliest and all But JB, what's the earliest, and all jokes aside, what's the earliest you'll get in your jammies? If I'm not going out at all, I never get out of them. I'll be in it all day.
Although, and you're telling me, I smell like juicy, disgusting juice. No one knows. Wait, what's the quote? What does it usually say? I usually say you smell like dirty, disgusting juicy juice. What did you just say? Yeah, something like that.
No, you usually smell like a chin chin. Yeah, that's true. This is true. But I mean, you always make fun of me because I, or what was it? I was wearing the same thing like all day long. You're like, you didn't take another shower? Yeah.
Yeah. You're taking the same shower. You'll wear the same. Would you both get into today? Here we are at the end of the day. Do you feel like you used today correctly? Mm-hmm. What did you waste today? I do. I thought that I'd see you.
I attacked the hill this morning. I took the kids to school, attacked the hill, didn't call either of you. I was on my journey, because I didn't want to get another impression of my breathless phone calls. And then... Were you zipped into your plastic sweatsuit? I was zipped into it. Your rubber bag. I'd love it if you actually had one of those. I'm weird.
I honestly, I haven't seen one of those since Rocky. It wasn't Rocky jogging in one of those. Yeah. He jogged and then then then it's some actor years later. Yes, and yes, I was just going to say Lawrence, Martin Lawrence. Martin Lawrence. Yeah. Ever that. Really. He had a job really long enough. And then and then I worked with Chappy this afternoon, we wrote for about four hours. So what does that look like, by the way, these writing sessions? Can I guess, are you, you're on a computer with him because he's over there in England, and he just sort of shares his screen with you, and you kind of watch him right. No. No.
Wrong. Yeah. I just get. Can you tell the camera? Chappy typo, Chappy typo. Yeah, I can tell the camera. Two lines up. Yeah, you forgot the apostrophe right there.
I, I, I just got back, we like about an hour ago from having a facial to answer your question. I treated myself. I haven't had one a long, long, long time. No, this is the kind where they, they pop.
Okay, I don't know. Okay, well, I'm trying to long, long, long time. No, this is the kind where they, they pop. Okay, I don't know. Okay. Well, I'm trying to fucking, you know, my wife's very diligent about making sure that I get in there and get my facial once a year. Yeah. Are you more frequent than that, Sean? No, maybe two a year.
When's the last time you had your toes and fingers done? Years and years. No, you've had a manicure and a pedicure. No, not for years and years and years. Well, don've had a manicure and petty cure. No, not for years and years and years. Will don't lie. Last man, he petty. Man, he had a no, but I've had two facials in the last six weeks. Are you serious? Yeah. Yeah. Because he had some on camera work. Did you? No, yeah, but you know what? I haven't had one in at least five years before that. Okay. And let's This explains a lot.
Yeah. It feels good though. Tell you what. I pass out. Yeah, me too. Yeah, I do too. Do you have one of those ugly wakeups when you're still like, oh my god. I totally do every time.
This is also relatable. I also had a massage recently when I, and, and, and we, I did a 90-minute massage. It's not that favorite. Everybody gets massages in the world. I don't get them all the time. And I had, and she levy, I was 90 minutes and she just kept me face down the full 90. And I was asleep. So I didn't know that I had it done like the flip over. And she was, and I fully did a, a dish woke up. And then my face had been in the donut, I'm facing down for 90 minutes. I look like I'd just been kicked in the face repeatedly. Yeah.
You know, our friend Justin Thoreau, you know, when he gets a massage for some weird reason, he likes to watch World War II documentaries. What are you talking about? That's not a bit. That's all he does when he gets a massage. So he'll put his face in the doughnut and he'll put his phone down on the floor and he'll just watch tanks and flame throwers. All kinds of carnage.
Where's the relaxing part? You tell me, this is like, I don't know, this is a guy that flies, you know, transcontinental topless. So try to figure him out. Does he really? Yeah, he falls asleep on a plane. He can't sleep without a shirt on. With a shirt on, he can't sleep.
So we've be sleeping on a plane or wherever he's sleeping, he's got to take a shirt off. That's just as gross as somebody putting their bare feet on the seat behind you on a plane. Like you know, JB, you just hit, you just hit the main vein of JB's disgust. What would be worse, walking around a hotel room without socks or shoes on or walking down the aisle way of a plane without a plane? Yeah, I'd say a plane plane for sure. Yeah, which is, which is a tight second.
Because you know, they don't, they don't like that. It's a cursory clean. They just go, ooh, okay, start you out in horror by when you go through the radar thing, you take your shoes off and you gotta put your socks there on the little foot outline thing and we'll have a hot socks have been from people all over the world.
And your hot sweaty feet have to go on exactly the same spot. Their hot sweaty feet just left. Oh, it's a fucking disaster. That's a great title for Simon. I love you, Doc. You know what, this is so good to hear you working off your long-term memory of what it's like going through an airport.
And I always try to straddle those little pain outs. Sure. Sure. And like, I step on the inside of the outside and like, no, no, no, no, inside the line, sir. Yeah, you gotta be inside. It's like a fucking murder chalk outline, okay? You gotta be right inside the satellite and then they get me out of here.
And then I gotta put them back in, then I put those hot socks back in my shoes. Now the shoes are ruined. Yeah. Why are the shoes ruined? They put the hot shoes? They put the hot shoes? You're transferring the germs. Yeah, and now they're dead to me.
Jason, you know what, you're gonna hate? What is it? The rest of the world. Yeah. The rest of the world. This is what you get at seven o'clock at night. I know it's frankly, Bateman. Well, you know what, the else. You get a seven a.m. too. I tell you what else you get at seven p.m. Yeah, this is the heck. You get yourself a heck of a guest. There we go. Oh shit. Will's taking a sip. I took a sip to make sure that I'm, that I'm queued up. You know what I mean? And I'm all sort of, I got a nice voice.
This guest better be fucking great, Arnad. This guest, you know this guest. And 720 at night. So this guest, okay, well let me ask you this, is how's a guest who's won a writer's guild of America award or a Grammy award? Grammy award. Great to, you got? Independent Spirit Award, a BAFTA, an Academy award. I apologize for my tone.
Our tonight's guest is one, all those things, okay. So maybe you want to hold your seven PM anger back a little bit. That was Sean. Okay. That was Sean. Are they a Tony Shive and he got, you know what he is? He is a Tony, he's a Are they a Tony Shive and he got. You know what he is? He is a Tony.
He's a Tony and an Emmy Shive and he got. He's been nominated for the Emmy. I don't know if he, a few times. I don't know if he's been nominated for a Tony, but I wouldn't be. I feel good to web you for this guest. He might get a webby. This guy, this guy does it all. He's a writer.
He's a director. He's a really funny performer, which I think people know because he's in a bunch of stuff that he directs. But I find him to be one of the funniest dudes that I know. He makes me laugh consistently, even though he's does some really serious stuff as well. We don't worry about what he does in the shadows. We're just worried about what he did with JoJo Rabbit. It's like a YTD. This is fully excused.
Polly excused. Don't get this. DANGER! Don't take a well done well. You're a very good, very good. I had this whole computer screen covered with this flapper paper that you told me to get. The time to get.
How did it feel now that it's sort of This is the first reveal of you guys too. Wow, I love the mustache. Well, what do you think? It's fantastic. Thanks buddy. I was happy that we prepping for a role this whole time, the strike is on. And I'm disappointed.
I'm disappointed. Wait, didn't you guys just work together? Isn't there, didn't the movie come out? Didn't they work together? Well, I didn't mention it, but we do have a thank you, Sean, for the promotion, because Tyga and... Great, thank you for your show.
Searchlight, light will love this Tyka's next film next goal wins is about to be released. I can't wait to see it Maybe at the time of this it is released and it's a great movie and it was made even better by some of the casting The trailer looks incredible. It does can't wait to see it. It's like look so Starlight you know, you said we just had done a movie together, completely forgot that. I know. I shot this movie so long ago,
and it's been so memorable performance, really. I know. I know. I know. By the way, it's all that shit on the other room floor. That's just the good stuff. Reminded it. We did.
We also did our flag means death, right around that same time together, which was, which is a series about pirates. It is. So just looking at the scoreboard, that's two for will zero for zero for Jason. Yeah. Don't worry. Listen, maybe when you're lucky, when you work with that guy, you won't remember you
having that at either. That would be exciting. Jason, I actually forgot to email you back about that other thing. Well, when I said I couldn't do to email you back about that other thing. Well, when I said I couldn't do the soccer movie, give it to Will. That you said me something. I wish. What did I say?
Did I send you something to look at? Maybe. So I'd be like that. You know you said me something. I don't remember things at all. Hey, where are you? Are you down? I just landed in L.A.
This is why it's late, and I appreciate you guys doing this at this hour. Oh, we appreciate you. I just went through that airport experience and I'm exactly like you, Jason. I can't stand it. Do you still have the dirty socks on right now? Yeah, I do. I do.
Straight from the airport. I don't want to touch it. Go burn them. But the thing, I kill my feet outwards, you know, when you stand on the edge. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Just put the pressure on the outside. I'm hoping to have less surface area touching the grid.
Yeah. Yeah. Will, at what point in the the pressure on the outside. Hoping to have less surface area touching the grid. Yeah. Yeah. Will, at what point in the interview can we talk about JoJo Rabbit? Do you have a plan for this? Do you have a bunch of questions? Well, let's talk about, no, no, you know, we never have a plan.
It's totally an apple. So we can talk about airports. Let's talk about JoJo Rabbit because if people haven't seen JoJo Rabbit, I heard you just fucking see it, I'm believe both. Right. Oh, sorry, I thought that's where you're going. It's the film that earned Tycat Academy Award for Best Adaptive Screenplay and film in
which you play Hitler. It's so funny. Yeah. You know, and take it easy, everybody. He's Jewish, okay? Take it easy. And also put that on the poster. Don't worry. He's Jewish. Take it Take it easy. And I should put that on the poster. Don't worry. He's
Jewish. Take it easy. You should have been on the poster. But folks, if you haven't seen it, don't be an idiot and we longer get out there and what was it? Help your career? Three years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. 2019. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two years. Two. Two. Two years. Two. Two years. Two. Two years. Two. Two years. Two years. Two. Two years. Two years. Two. Two years. Two. Two years. Two. Two years. Two years. Two. Two years. Two. Two years. Two. Two years. Two. Two years. Two. Two. Two years. Two. Two. Two. Two. Two years. Two. Two. Two. Two. Two. Two. Two. Two. Two. Two. Two. Two. Two. Two. Two. Two. Two. Two. Two. Two. Two. Two 2019 actually yeah so take it actually walk us through that a little bit I'm curious because you adapted that from a book What was how did that go down that you were like oh man? This has to be a movie what what was that process like for you my mother read this book called Cajing Skies And she pitched it to me she said you should make this into a movie and the way she pitched the story to me I found so funny and And I thought, this is fantastic. And then I've read the book, and it was the least funny book I've read in a long time. And there was no imaginary Hitler in any of that stuff, but the way that she described what was going on in this world, I thought,
I'll go with her pitch. Anyway, and I added just those other elements to it, like Hitler. So what was it? It was a kid going to a Hitler youth camp. Yeah, it was about a little kid who wanted to be the best Nazi in the world. Very topical right now. And he tried... And then he got home. He gets home one day and he finds that his mother's hiding a girl in their attic, a Jewish girl in their attic, and he has an absolute meltdown.
There's no idea what to do about this thing. Which I was here. Imagine this is like, you know, he's been taught that they're monsters with horns and, you know, devil towels and stuff. I mean, for people who haven't seen it, it's just so goddamn good. And it just, the plane lands at the end of this thing in a way
that is so exciting and elegant and fun. And it's just, I don't know how you threaded that needle totally all the way through the film and then an even narrower one at the end and just drilled it. Thanks. It's true and and my question was so you did play Hitler were you always were you always going to play that part where you like I got to do this or did that how did that? No I never imagined I mean look I'm you know I'm brown and too good looking, some would say.
You're very, very, very, very handsome. A few are, but we did put it out to a lot of actors and I don't even think they got to see the script. I think their agents immediately said there's a hard, no, it's a hard pass on this one. So is it easy pass? So then a few, and I went and made a few other movies I thought, when I was going to make this, it'll be one of those blacklist scripts that never gets off the blacklist. And then searchlight, who made this soccer film with us,
they said to me, we really want to make this film, but only if you play Hitler. And see, these guys, I mean, consistently through multiple administrations have been like one of the most courageous, tasteful companies in all of their game. I can't imagine a bunch of other companies that would have said, yes, what was the pitch process like when you went in there about like, you know, exactly what it was like. Well, but I mean, did you, did you, did you have your agent sort of, you know, soften the
ground a little bit and say, he's gonna pitch your Hitler film, but it's not like what you, I mean, was there any warning at all? No, no, no, no. And we went through multiple studios and started with, okay, it's about a kid growing up in World War II, who's in the Hitler youth. And then the eyes would glaze over, you see them fidget uncomfortably in their seat, and I would sort of just trail off from there. So you just know instantly that it's not for them. But like from jump, though, the way that you play and introduce Hitler is just like,
oh, I'm in. I'm wearing great hands. That, only this is going, they're not going to ask me to fall in love with Hitler. They're not going to, like, I think it was helpful that you didn't look, you'd terribly like the classic Hitler. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I think it was helpful that you didn't look, you'd terribly like the classic hit. Yeah, yeah, yeah. I also think what helped with not having a big star play, that role as a would've overshadowed everything else,
the whole story itself would've been the... Gussie, the Tom Cruise hit the movie. Right. So Tom Cruise passed on it. Well, we had some news. Okay. It was just so, so great. It's so good. And so, so you do that.
I mean, this is like, it's such a, um, yeah, it's Jason said. I mean, it's, it, and it sounds like very sort of high brow. And it is, but at the same time, it's very accessible. And it, and it's just so, I don't know, there's something really, and it's playful and it's real, and there's a lot going on, and it really hits you in so many different ways. And I like a film like that, where you can't describe it as...
It's not really a comedy, it's not really a drama. It's sort of... Yeah. Trids that little path in between the things. And, you know, I needed to make it, you know, we've all seen great Holocaust films, you know, Schindler's list and so forth. And I don't think I could have made one of those
very serious films. And we've seen so many of them. And I think if you want to get a message across or talk about something like heavy like that, you've got to find different ways of telling that story. And one way which I think is the most important way of telling stories like that is using humor. But you weren't even asked for a laugh. You were simply just in this wonderful kids perspective.
And that just allowed you so much latitude. I think it wasn't really Hitler. It wasn't really Hitler's is an imaginary Hitler from the mind of an 11 year old boy. So you can only know what an 11 year old knows. Right. Why is it buffooned and an idiot? Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. It's great. I love when like Jews tackle that topic. It's just beautiful. Like Mel Brooks always you, you know, Spielberg, just I love the dichotomy of them telling the story from their point of view, you know, from their artistic point of view. You don't want to see Hitler movie from me.
No, no, no, not at all, not with a mustache like that. Okay. He never got this one. And we will be right back. Smartless fans, listen up. Have you heard, you can listen to episodes of this very show, AdFree, and one week early on Amazon Music with your Prime Membership? That's right, all your favorite smartless episodes can be heard on Amazon Music AdFree,
and you'll always be the one to catch our new episodes so you can brag to your friends. But that's not all you can listen to any of your other favorite shows like, I don't know, Bad Dates, and Just Jack and Will, early, and ad-free too. They also have favorites like the daily part might take an up first all without any ads. You know what this means? Uninterrupted listening, so no more cliff hangers. Amazon Music offers the most ad-free top podcast
so we know they definitely have something for you. And it's already included in your prime membership. Till listen now, all you need to do is go to Amazon.com, slash smartlist, that's Amazon.com, slash smartlist, or download the Amazon Music App. It's just that easy. This message is brought to you by our sponsor, Visit Florida.
Why not escape to Paradise on your next vacation? Check out Naples, Marco Island, and the Everglades, Florida's Paradise Coast. Dip into turquoise waters on the over 30 miles of pristine Gulf Shoreline. From the secluded Key Whadon Island to Luxury Beachfront Resorts, there's a spot for everyone.
Outdoor adventurers, brace yourself for an exhilarating playground of endless mangroves. I like those estuaries and shorelines to experience plus boating, fishing, diving and an abundance of golf courses. Singing a little pampering, diving to opulence with upscale boutique's art galleries and world-class spa's nestled in Naples.
Nestled in Naples is the name of my biography. I mean, come on, what's more relaxing than lounging amid cypress trees to the soothing sounds of golf breezes? If food's more your thing, you can save a fusion of flavors with fresh from the golf, seafood and globally inspired cuisine at Top Natch restaurants.
The dining scene on Paradise Coast is a feast for the senses, for the finest of everything Florida has to offer, only Paradise will do. Visit paradisecoast.com slash smartless to start planning your trip today! This episode has brought to you in part by WeWork, the world's leading flexible space provider. Who doesn't like working flexibility, right? I'm in my pajamas recording these ads right now.
Don't you wish you had visual as well as audio? But that's beside the point. I can imagine the flexibility that WeWork offers is fantastic. You can come and go as you please. It's your space. It's significant to you and your needs. It seems like a dream come true for anybody that wants a flexible work schedule.
The world of work has changed whether fully remote in office or somewhere in between. People are looking for spaces that inspire, connect, and help with productivity and collaboration to give their businesses an edge. Enter, we work. Their solutions are inherently flexible and built for all the ways people work today.
We work as solutions for individuals and for companies no matter what the size, from co-working memberships to hundreds of work spaces around the world, and dedicated office space for teams of all sizes to collaborate. Their space is foster collaboration and connectivity, bring teams together in person and work alongside some of the most innovative companies today.
Get the flexibility your team needs with monthly memberships without the long term commitments that can change just as easily as your needs do. WeWork makes it easy. Get into a turnkey office with furniture, wifi, and other amenities ready to use on day one without all the upfront costs. Interested in finding out more visit WeWork.com slash smartless. Be sure to use our URL so they know we sent you. That's WeWork.com slash SmartLess. We work. And now back to the show.
Hey, let me ask you this. You touched on it, Tyken. It's one of the things I said sort of in my rough intro, but you are such a super hilarious dude, just as a person. And I think that one of your superpowers is using, you always find a way to make everything you do fun and funny. Like, even, by the way, even our flag means death, which is kind of a love story between these two guys. And it's, but it's a pirate show, but it's really a comedy, but I mean, it's more of a
comedy probably than a lot of your other stuff, but you always have such great elements of humor. And I know that you use it in your real life, too. And it's one of the things that I like. I'm drawn to other people who can have a sense of humor about A themselves and B that no matter what how serious a subject is, that there's always a way to access it through humor, to sort of undercut it. And how important is that to you when you're thinking about making stuff?
Because you don't get really like to earnest really? No, well coming from New Zealand we have a very sensitive cheesiness meter. When we see something we feel like it's a bit cringey, we try and avoid doing it. And I think all the best comedies I've ever seen have just had that real mix of light and dark. And that's what life is every day. It's full of tragedy and comedy. And that's what I like my films. And the things I do to just have a mix of both those things. What were some of those growing up that you loved? One of your favorite movies that were inspirations?
Well, growing up, I mean, the things I loved, you know, really young black out of, and like British TV comedies, like Faulty Towers and things like that, which was, you know, one of my favorite. Real straight comedies, but they did it really efficiently and really well. That, you know, I think Strangelov
is one of the best comedies that's been made. I love the graduate. One of the best comedies I've ever seen is Final of the Concords, which you were a part of. And I thought when that came out, I was like, well, my life has changed. That's the funniest show I've ever seen in my life. Yeah, Jermaine and Brett have been tested in, you know, Jermaine, I write with Still and it makes off with him a lot now. Time bandits were making a TV. We're turning that into a TV show. Yeah. Oh, you are. That's awesome. I love that. We still do a lot of writing together,
and he's still, I think, the best writer. Oh, no. How did you, yeah, I want to know, how did you and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, and, show thing and we saw each other in the library and I think instantly took a dislike to each other just the best of way we look and then it took about two or three months before we started to get on and and there there would be a best made citizens. Fuck with with all of your success and artistic accolades and all that stuff, you now I'm sure can
a pitch like JoJo Rabbit would not be quite as difficult because people trust you. How did you find, when you started your career, you had that sense of humor that was in the cheese meter. In other words, you wouldn't go to the extremes to make an audience feel super comfortable, hold anybody's hand like this country, Hollywood, a lot of the people in charge, will ask you to do.
They won't really give you the latitude to kind of keep the edges of that. How did you get through that period and not just hit fuck it? These people don't get what I've got. I did think that all the time and still do. I think it's so funny here. You have to explain everything. Everything that gets made. You want to just say, just let me show you some footage, but they're never like that.
Yeah, but I mean, even to the audience, you have to explain everything throughout the story, every beat of the way. And so there are no surprises. There's no putting trusting the filmmaker to deliver the story in their own way. But I would just come to, I'd make film in New Zealand, I'd come here and show it at the Sundance or something and no one would see it. And then studios would say, do you want to do this film and be, you know, some, I'm not going to say horrible, but it's like a wrong calm or something and no one would see it and then studios would say, do you want to do this film and be a, you know, some, I'm not going to say horrible, but, you know, like it's like a wrong calm or something that wasn't really up my, um, out my alley. And then I'd think, nah, I'll go back to New Zealand and make another thing. And
I just kept doing that about four or five times until, uh, finally I did. And then what we're doing in the shadows was really the one that kind of, I think had more attraction, um, in the States, even though really the one that kind of I think had more attraction In the States even there was still a kind of small cult issue, but it was that HBO? No, it was that there was a film and then we turned that into a show their Marvel asked me to come in and pitch it on thought Yeah, well you did you did Well, I'm for the wilder people in between that. Yeah, yeah, I'm for the world of people and that I don't know how these films did actually. I don't really remember. Are you getting checks?
You're getting a lot of checks in the mail. You know, all the checks. I think that's what he's checking. But I was gonna say, so then you do, but you do that stuff. You know, it's funny, we were working, like I mean, Steph and Tyke goes, we have worked together before it.
And at this point, he had made two or three films in New Zealand. Okay, so he was like a legitimate filmmaker. And like he said, like you had, you'd open it, Sundance, at least twice, I think, and whatever. And he'd done this video. Sean, I think Sean's in it too, isn't he? Is Sean in it? Maybe not.
We did for like an upfront, like a... It was for the Super Bowl. Super Bowl for NBC. If the NBC and it was going through all the shows on NBC, and it was the brotherhood of man, like, song from their musical, and they cut it all the different shows. How to succeed? And it did a verse or a couple of lines from the show.
And it cut to me and Maya and Christina Applegate and Maya Rudolph and me. And Taggy goes, we have work together. And he shows me that. Yeah, I'm pretty. That's how it was. Was it in that? Yeah, it was. It was in that Donald Trump.
It was a direct. I directed. I directed Trump. Really? Did you have a set of specifications that you have in your YouTube? Yeah, there was a piece of paper with a list of demands. Like, is like, the way that he likes to be lit. The height of the camera?
The height of the camera? Exactly. It had to be a certain height to make him look a little thinner. And yet, I think it had like a sort of whatever the pantone of orange was that he had to be appear as on screen. Wow. Wow.
It was sort of like a makeup person who was also his ego booster. So she would touch him up and say, oh Mr. Trump, oh Mr. Trump, you're so nice. Oh, yeah. Wait, was I in that? Were you in that? I don't know, maybe.
I don't know if you were in the reboot. I don't know, I don't know if you were in the promo. But I was like, but it's so funny. So here's Tyke like fucking like, it's not like he discovered talent late in his life. Like he had it. And but he's coming to America and they're offering him rom comes and he's like, now, and he'll make a couple bucks doing some video shit for people like for the Super Bowl. And then he fucks off back to New Zealand and to make his like indies and do what he
wants. And what made you think that, you know, Marvel is so incredible at doing, at doing their, their thing. I mean, they've got a product that is just incredible. It is, made this industry twice as healthy as it's ever been. But I think you, one should and does and needs to adhere to a certain, um, the parameters, the parameters of the like, needs to adhere to a certain The parameters the parameters of like because that audience expects a certain boxes to be checked What made you think that your incredibly unique perspective on things would be a fit for something that you would probably agree It needs to stay inside a certain a certain boundary. Jason. That's wonderful question. I thank you Yeah, really close zero. Thank you. Is it a wonderful question? Yeah, thank you. I'm glad you are that's wonderful question. I think you
Zero thank is a wonderful question. Yeah, thank you. I'm glad you are thank you Will. Did you hear all that? I didn't know I said it's a wonderful yeah, a lot of still a lot of compliments I'm asking in the glove the question to be on still really I'd get such a hard hitting so late to it would be our so articulate. I have another one. Hey To watch you to watch you suck Marvel's dick for so long, it's gonna be a treat. I took it all. Did you say you did take it all? Yeah, right down to the cubes.
Let's get the answer now. Okay. Oh my gosh. Oh my god. Jason watched a skateboard in this free time. Oh, Fuck it. What happened to me? You know what?
I had no interest in doing one of those films. It wasn't on my whole plan of my career and all to it. But I was poor and I just had a second child. And I thought, you know what? This would be a great opportunity to feed these children. Or do it my dad did. Go ahead. Continue. I'm still doing my answer.
No, no. Yeah. Yeah. Hang. Okay. So then they called and they said, do you want to do this? And Thor was probably the face that was probably the least popular franchise. It was the, I had never read Thor comics when I was a kid.
That was the comic I picked up. Oh. And then I thought, and I, and I, and I, and I, and I, and I, and I, and I never read Thor comics when I was a kid. That was the comic I picked up and said, oh, but then I thought, and then I just researched on it. And I read one full comic, or still 18 pages of how long that I was still baffled by this character. And I thought, well, you know, I can bring to this. Let me know when it comes to comics. I mean, red is a stretch. Okay, go ahead, sorry.
I'm going to look that. It looked dead. I flipped through, you know, and then pitched myself. I thought the only thing that I could bring is, I'm, you know, it's a character. It's like just looking at Thor as a character in Luke, yeah, he's like a billionaire lives in space. And, you know, he's got these just,
who looks ridiculous and that was sort of the end. I was like, well, this is highlight that. He's like a rich kid who, and I pitched that he's a bit like you and me Jason, that he hates germs. Right. And, you know, that didn't scare the shit out of them.
I think there was no place left to go with that thing. Right, right, right. I was like, you felt like, I thought, wow, they called me in. This was really the bottom of the barrel. But Figgy has taken a nice swings on it. He has taken great. Right. I'm starting with Favreau, right? And then I mean, like,
and Kenneth Brana and Chloe Zhao and the Rousseau's. I guess it has been directors that have been outside of the box, but they know what they're good at, right? They're good at keeping everyone in their lane and making sure that they don't veer off into something else that doesn't feel marvel. So they bring people into a good story and making great characters and like, you know, bring something unique and then they'll keep it within the marvel. And you obviously had a great experience
because you went back for one. Yeah, yeah, I'm a bit... But it is true, like I remember, we have friends of ours who are doing another, one of these, I won't name it, but it's a series of movies that takes place in space. And they went off a little bit, I think, feared a little bit off the plan and ended up not working out because they had too many ideas that were outside of Marvel though.
No, no, no, I didn't say it was Marvel. I said it's a different, a different thing. But it was outside of the playbook a little bit, right? And so that it made them nervous because they got a lot of staggers, they're property and they got a lot of stag. So when they hired you, though, Tyka, I mean, again, knowing. The fans hated it by the way. They hated the, I was doing it. They hated Thor. No, the fact that I was doing it when I was running on the first one. And they're like, who's this guy? He's going to be like, no, but they fucking, they fucking end up loving it. My kids who are big Marvel fans, like my son
Abel still to this day. When I told him that you were on the show tonight, he was like, wait, he's on the show tonight because he loves fucking Thor. So much. He's an idiot though. He's not in it. He's a funny fucking kid. He's not a, he's not a, he's not a, he's not a, dollar like you. Wait, Tyka, you get a compliment of Archi, you got to. When you hear, when you hear that about seven, this is the seven o'clock vision. We're going to throw out your guess. Babes 45 minutes past gummy hour. And he's not starting to shake.
And he's got the fight. It is not pleasant. Man, no, let him in. A man is going to, Texan been saying, you take that coming and 50 minutes later, you can come in house. She lived it on the front staff. I don't know. Top of the mailbox.
I was, I put the key next to the key. I take out places outside, waiting for it to kick in and then it's just a scratch. Coming on. Not a bang at the door. Yeah. And she's looking at her watch. She's like, $30, $ Oh, coming on. No, no, no. It's not a bang at the goal. Yeah. And she's looking at her watch. She's like, 30, 29, 28. Thank you.
Tyka, when you hear that, that fans, like you said, were maybe heavy. OK. Next question. The, the, the, the, almost little that you know, spit today. And then I have to ask about Mandalorian because I'm a massive, massive, massive, massive fan of that series.
And so, Scottie and my husband, and how did you get Mandalorian? And how, by the way, and you voiced the droid, right? The IG 11? I do it all. And I'm like, John, so fat, right?
What did he voiced? Sean? The droid. The IG 11. Sorry, what's a serial number on the right? Yeah, I do. I do. I do. I do. I do. I do. I do. I make sure to make sure to have that on the top of your head. Yeah.
Fuck it. This is how you landed Scotty. I always Yeah. Hey, you and I do. I'm going to put you when you your headstone when you die your grave so it's just going to be blank. Just to be nothing. Not even a date. Just no, it's so sorry. It'll say I apologize. Yeah gonna be nothing, not even a date. No, that's so sorry. It'll say I apologize. Yeah, it fucking nothing. So John said,
Anyway, IG 11, people walk by, oh that's shiny. Well, IG 11, who show on the nose based on IG 88, that's correct. Wow, which is something I found out when I did the Mandalorian. Did that floer you as much as it's flooring me? What you're about to say, Fabro, picked you up and said, He picked me up. I was at the standing on Coney, picked me up, said,
Come, kid, come and do an episode of Mandalorian. I went down, this is the first time I've used that volume thing, but the TV screen's all in a big circle Yeah, we shot most of the show on that And he said come and do this this thing and it was great Because I didn't have to write it and do things just turn up and direct and it was awesome And he was there to help and the first day I was directing 75 stormtroopers. Oh wow standing a big giant stormtrooper battle. That was so cool. Oh fucking incredible
Oh my god. It is cool And by the way, it's good that you had a guy like Favre we like he's a friend of the show and we like him a lot Wow, Stan, a big giant storm tree, but battle. That's so cool. Just fucking incredible. Oh my god. By the way, it's good that you had a guy like Favreau. We like, he's a friend of the show, and we like him a lot. Love that giant Favreau. Yeah, same year. And I'm sure he was fucking helpful as shit, because he's a cool dude.
Yeah. Taker, why, so why did you just fly into LA, and where were you? I went to Scotland, because I was hanging out in Scotland. And so just hanging out. Airbnb, at the special little pop-up places you can stay. I don't know if you heard about this, but they made Shrek's swamp with Shrek's house, a full replica of Shrek's tree and the house inside it, and everything is exactly like the move, the bed table. Rita is...
Your wife, Rita. My wife, yeah, amazing. So she booked us and we went and stayed at the Shrek. Hold on. Then we drove around Scotland and we dressed up. She made it, she bought costumes. Oh, I can't keep it right. We dressed up as Shrek and Princess Fiona.
She did some photos and stuff. There goes. What are you doing? Your free time question. Wait a second. Jason, the disgust of Jason's face. I just can't have a chance. Can I have 20 minutes of the interview real quick?
So you are married to your datinger. We don't. And, all right, so you are married to, you were dating her. We don't worry. And now, and now- I'm writing a single song right now. We're married. And now you're married. Yeah.
Did you know that she was such a fan of Shrek before you put a ring on her finger? No, no, you don't know that. So she's a big Shrek fan such that you went ahead and bought yourself a couple of first class tickets all the way over to Scotland. And you stayed in a little grasshopper. Yeah. And it was just part of the trip. There was just one fun thing we got to do.
You get that's fun, I guess. And then we drove around Scotland. We went hang out and look at the castle. That's pretty cool. I guess that's pretty cool. Now, if they had, now Sean, don't lie, if they had a place like this Airbnb that was Star Wars themed, would you take Scotty to, for his birthday surprise? Yeah. Without a doubt.
Yeah. Would you fly all the way to Scotland for it? Do you love him that much? Probably not. Would you go to space for it? It could exist in space. You wouldn't. Well, space is fast.
Would you like to go to space? Sean, absolutely. Don't you? Would you? No, honestly not. Absolutely. Now, I played golf today with Michael Strahan, who told me that he went up into that Jeff Bezos rocker thing, and I would do that.
You would do that? Absolutely. Now, I just... I think, would you go to space? Yeah, I'd go to space. If I had a long. Oh, great question. Just a couple minutes.
I mean, what we... That's just a couple minutes. That Bezos thinks a couple minutes. I mean, what we... That's just a couple minutes. That baseless thing's a couple minutes. I just don't want to do anything that when I land the euphoria is relief because I got away with something. I feel like, you know, I just... I shouldn't be doing things that I get away with anymore. Well, that's how we feel about our careers.
Yeah, that's true. Jason's like one of those dogs. You know, they have those colors and they set up the perimeter. And the perimeter is the golf club at his house. Okay. And if he goes any further, if I can shock some and it keeps him, you know, I would say. But Jay, it's a once in a lifetime thing that you could just experience the view of space and the weightlessness and like, you can't ever always love the weightlessness, Jay. Come't ever oh he's love the weightlessness Jake
You know what you know what you know what you actually you end up getting very bloated up there Do you think so? Yeah, you know I know so you see no shots of the astronaut say it's really everybody you're taking away from the astronaut From talking to people in spaces. They look bloated man little too bloated little too But in the hair all stands up. I'm kidding. You know, I lean into all this stuff. I don't care about the germs. Scotland sounds great with this threat thing. And let's just get a parachute on me and get a plane going. This is all for bits. Yeah, I would love it would be great. I was just now thinking about Scotland. I was thinking about JB in like medieval times. Oh, and like people were like ripping, ripping, you know, ripping legs off of chickens and stuff
at the meal and just, you know, biting into it and like, you know, just washing those hands. Damn. Castle with nobodies had that an invented socks really yet. No plumbing. No plumbing, no bath. The toilet paper. Oh. We'll be right back. Thanks to Amazon for their support with their low prices and huge selection, Amazon wants to help you share joy this holiday season.
And as we all know, the holidays are all about these joyful moments. I remember just a week ago, through Amazon, I ordered a little bracelet with all the planets on it because I'm a little bit of a sci-fi nerd. And guess what, I got two of them. And guess who the other person is that I gave it to. Scotty, so guess what, we both have them.
And guess what was shared? Joy, tremendous joy between two people that love each other that now have planet beads on their wrists. It's pretty cool. And it's these types of moments that Amazon can help you create during the holidays, however you share joy, make it happen with holiday deals at Amazon.
Thank you to Sonos for supporting this episode. Elevate your audio experience to a whole new level with Sonos ARC, the premium smart sound bar that transcends ordinary listening. Arc was designed from the inside out for incredibly clear sound and rich bass, then fine-tuned by Oscar and Grammy-winning producers, mixers, and artists. True play tuning software further enhances your listening experience by optimizing Arc's sound for the unique acoustics of the room. Feel the immersive power of cinematic sound as Sonos arc unleashes crystal clear
room-filling sound with Dolby Atmos. When the TV is off-stream music podcast smart list, the radio, audio books, and more using the new Sonos app Apple Airplay 2 or guess what, your voice. So me in this house for me and Scotty, we have Sonos in every single room in our house and we just got the Aero 100. It's pretty cool. When we go in the backyard and we're sitting around we have a little tiny fireplace back there and we just use the Sonos Aero 100 and it's hooked up to our phone. We can play all of our favorite music but it sounds so much better with Sonos. Head over to Sonos.com and hooked up to our phone. We can play all of our favorite music, but it sounds so much better with Sonos.
Head over to Sonos.com and enjoy up to 25% off select products now through November 27th or while supplies last. Smartless listener, let me tell you a little bit about the Defender 110. You're up for any challenge that comes your way. The Defender 110 is too. The iconic vehicle has been re-imagined for 21st century adventure and its unparalleled off-roadability, as well as its robust interior,
are invaluable whether you're headed towards uncharted territory or just a weekend of exploration. The Defender 110 tackles challenging surroundings with absolute confidence. The SUV conveys strength outside and in, featuring peerless technology like intuitive driver display and an award-winning infotainment system to keep you connected no matter where the journey takes you. Adventure is unique to everyone and so is the defender. Choose from the two-door defender 90, the four-door defender 110, or the larger defender 130 with the ability to seat up to eight passengers, you'll find uncompromising performance in all three. Pack up and go even further with a Defender 110. Learn more at landroberusa.com forward slash Defender.
All right, back to the show. I want to know, speaking of all these little things, take out what's it like, like you seem, I don't, we don't know each other that well, we met once and it was like a such a highlight of, you know, my life meeting, I'm such a huge fan, I've seen all your other that well, we met once, and it was like such a highlight of, you know, my life meeting, I'm such a huge fan, I've seen all your movies, I love JoJo Rabbit,
I've seen it like three times. And... Tyka has no recollection. No, of course not. I remember I almost put your jacket on, do you remember that? I remember that. It was a great time.
It was a highlight for me as well. Okay, so, no, like so what, the little bit I know of you, you seem completely relaxed, low, key, chill, like normal, down to earth. What do you do? He just mentioned he's married, by the way, so just fucking cool it.
What do you do when you meet a personality that's totally opposite of yours, that you have to work with, you're like, oh my God, this guy or this girl's way too much for me. They're not on my level. How do you deal with that? Um, I just, I just bitch about them later. You send all your notes in through the first AD.
Yeah. And then I got home and this son of a bitch. I believe this guy. Um, this way we'll do that. Yeah. I mean, actors in particular, just hard work. And then each actor's got a different way of working that you got to find out because they won't tell you and you got to figure it out by watching them and you're like, oh, you got them. Yeah, yeah, yeah. You're one of them. And then there's all the other
ones that are, let's do an in-protection. Oh No, they take a one for me now, right? Yeah, yeah, and those guys who like Talk about this a lot with crew loves that they go Let's do an in-protection like all right like are you at the point though in your career where you're just like you know I'm gonna hand pick the people I want the actors Just people you trust and you're friends.
But what are we going to say to that guy? You're a bad improviser. You know, you fucking roll the camera and then there, you know, a lot of actors idea of improvising with ad libbing is just say the first thing that comes into your head doesn't have to help the scene at all or anything. They go, actually, cool wall. Yeah. seen it all or anything, they go, actually go cool wall. Yeah.
And then you're like fantastic. Well done. All right. That was the one for you. Let's move on. All right. Or it's just a list of jokes that 100% wrote the night before. All right.
Ian Morris texted me out of the blue today just so I can get a mention on E.S. who Ian, who co-wrote next goal wins. He's our mutual friend. And. So that's. Sorry, so it's about soccer, yeah. And Willie, what do you play in the film? Nothing, I have it.
I can't mean. Take a ask me last minute to come in and just do a couple days to help out. But. A small, small little role. Yeah. But he makes a huge difference. The film is about the, it's a true story about the worst soccer team in the world,
which is the American Samoan soccer team. And in the history of the country, they'd never won a game or scored a goal. Wow. And I think like in 2001 or something, they suffered the biggest international loss, which is still the record today, which was against Australia, and they
lost 31 nil. Jesus. Let's figure that out. What does that, a goal every three minutes? Was anybody in the goal? Was there a goal tender? He was going in the goal. I think he was quite traumatized by that.
And they lost to the Sakharoaru, who is not the best soccer team in the world. But, but DC. And then they got this coach in Thomas Rongen. They, I think you might have been the only person who responded to the, to the request. He came into the island and got them in shape and then they ended up spoiling it. They scored a goal. Yeah. Yeah. And it was a big and that person, the guy playing that part is Michael Fassbender, who is a fantastic dude. That man is gifted. Really an actor.
And it was funny because he's done so many serious, really heavy. He's got a new series movie coming out next to him as well. He's someone you can improve for us. He's very good. He's a a new series movie coming out next to him soon as well. He's someone you can him for us. He's very good. He's a smart dude. He's so good in the killer too, the venture film. It's fantastic. I want to see that too.
I want to see that too. But anyway, and so you have fast bender in there in a very sort of like comedic role. Mm-hmm. Yeah. Right? And I didn't think it would be that his role would become his comeder. I thought that everyone else around him would provide the comedy. But he was just, he kept delivering and just gave him more things to do.
Yeah. Was it, was it, was it twisting arms to get him in that film? Because, you know, he's, he's much more interested in racing cars right now. Is it a race car driver? Yeah. Yeah. He was doing that when I called him up. He was, he had to fit it in in between races. Yeah, he's there.
Well, I'm thinking about taking the year off and just racing. He's legit. He's legit, but I said, well, that's in Hawaii. And he said, I'll be there. Yeah. Yeah. He's got this love. He's got the fast bitters.
He's got one of the, like, the more you ask him about what's going on in his life, the cooler it is, because he's like, yeah, I mean, while racing this type of BMW, then I race this kind of thing, and then where's that? Well, we drove, we're in Portugal, and then we drove up to, fuck, Belgium to do that thing, and you're like,
what kind of life is this? This is a fucking life, I'm not. This is real Steve McQueen life. Yeah, it's a real Steve McQueen life. Like, cool. This channel of that whole life, he's Steve McQueen life. Yeah, it's a real Steve McQueen like cool channeled that whole life. He's stolen that whole life. He raised Le Mans. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Fucking a tiger. What how much time do you spend in New Zealand versus the states? Depending on what text department is sure, sure. It changes. It changes. It changes. It changes. It changes like a horse.
How you should have said it in a number of days, I can stand each place. And you do the right one for each one of those, for sure. Yeah, yeah. I have about 14 days left this year in the States. I bring Siri. Wow, really? I'm a serious. Well, you've time.
I'm going to get out of here. Yeah. Yeah. But, uh, no, I just, I try to spend a lot of time in New Zealand because my kids are there and, uh, I'm just to get out of here. Yeah. But I just feel, I try to spend a lot of time in New Zealand, because my kids are there and I'm just trying to come here because I want to see Will. Are they going to love this movie? Are they soccer fans? No, they don't care about soccer.
New Zealand is not a soccer country. No, it's rugby, right? It's rugby. It's all rugby. Are you a rugby fan? I'm a massive rugby fan. Really? We just went to the World Cup games. I just saw that. World Cup and just tell you how they go. How did they do? We just went to the World Cup games. I just saw that World Cup and just...
I watched that. Tell you how they do. We got to the final and then we lost. Barely lost. To South Africa. To South Africa. You guys are the two powerhouses, right? Yeah.
Well, hang on. The spring box, South Africa, barely beat England. Let's be honest. They were kind of charmed this tournament. Yeah. And, and New Zealand had a really good chance, uh, to win a good chance. We often, it's, it's always close between those teams. Did you ever play rugby as a kid?
I played rugby up until my sort of late 20s. I mean, you can, you, it really hurts, doesn't it? There's no padding. It's still, I get up in the morning and like sometimes this, you know, an ankle won't work or a knee won't work. Well, there's little injuries you get in your 20s and your bounce back, where it's fast and now it's like your body, then your body just punishes you later. Some people say that it's safer to tackle in that sport because there's no helmets.
You're actually a little bit more careful. We don't tackle with your head. Over here, they just just dive through the air with their head first, trying to stab people with the head. There's over here, they just sort of just just like just dive through the air with the head first. Yeah, trying to stab people with their bodies. Well, when the CTE stories were all about in the last five, 10 years or something like that, there was a thought that maybe NFL would think about removing the helmets.
Really? Yes, so that people would stop using their head as part of the tackle. And all the other pads would still be on. You just have to learn how to just tackle differently, like the folks play rugby. Yeah, you just tackle and move your head out of the way. Are they really less than rugby, the CTE? It seems like they have less questions.
Less concussion. Less concussion. Wow, that's kind of amazing. Because you don't have that false sense of safety. Yeah, you protect yourself. Don't make sure your head doesn't bang in anything. That's interesting. Mm-hmm.
All right. So, Tyka, hi. What about like, when you're directing something? Tyka, each time he told me, he said, hi. Hi. As if this might be usable for the first part of the industry. Sure, forget. We're not even in this. We may cut him, but it's starting before this.
Yeah, we are. I'm sorry. So, it's like, um, great answer. So, it's guess is take away TT, take away, welcome. Hey, take a question about your process. Uh, the, when you, uh, are directing something, is, is there an itch to be in it always? Are you like, oh, God, I'm so glad I'm not in this. No, I really love being in it.
I love, I love acting. I think it's fun, but only if it's something that I find fun. And I've got control over that. Do you like the process of directing yourself, the fact that you don't, you do it? Yeah, well, I like it because it's easy if we did direct people in the scene as well. I can talk straight to them while I'm doing the lines. Yeah, do it.
I do it in the lines. What if you have an actor that's not very pliable with all of that? Like, they get upset that you're talking to them in the middle of the scene that they want you to wait till after cut. You ever had one of those? It's pretty lucky I haven't worked with people like that. Yeah. Maybe one or two, but I just sort of tend to ignore it.
Kind of kind of cut them out of the cool group and then just ignore them and then they go out and then pay the quit or just alienated and believe them on set. Yeah, I mean films, it's like high school. Do you have siblings that have cool names like you too? Yeah, most people have got cool names. My kids have got really cool names. My first daughter, her first name is DeKainga or DeHenika,
which means house or home of the she-hawk. Wow. Yeah, and my second daughter, Matiwa, the literal translation is time of the dead. Wow, wow. That's awesome. Be careful what you name your kids. You know that that Sean's that Sean means I like macaroni? Yeah, so it's not a lot of people know that. Not a lot of people know that, but you could.
I like macaroni. That's the only if you spell it SEAN. You spell it SH AWN and we'll tell them what that means. That's Jason's improv. I like setups. I don't like punchlines. And you say the other part. You say the other part.
Take an action. You've got a poem you wrote. About the situation. About the situation. About the situation. About the situation. About the situation. Exactly.
Exactly. Tell them. Tell them what you wrote. Tell them what you wrote. and then point at the person. We did this fucking stupid bit for a long time. Ty could have were doing on the on taxing each other. And he was and we were doing flag means death. And there was a scene where we're res,
Derby Reese has to walk away. And I said something to his character. And then Ty could come up by me and goes, Reese, Derby Reese has to walk away and I said something to his character and then it comes up by me and goes, don't man, let him, let him go, man, or something like this. But he said it in this like we were laughing because he was doing it on purpose to sound like it was like in an after school special. I mean, grab my arm like, just let him go, man. And so, just let him go, Johnny, we'll get him next year.
And we started laughing. He's so fucking hard and everybody's like, what are you guys laughing about? And he kept going, don't worry about it, Johnny. They were never like us. We were always outside of this, Johnny. The fucking director was like, you guys got a fucking cool at man. And then we were texting each other these stupid things.
It's fun stuff, you know what I mean? Yeah, it sounds like a good time. It does sound like a good good. It's not funny anymore Johnny. People got hurt. We killed a kid, Johnny. It's not a game anymore. People are getting hurt. Fuck me, that gets me every time. Tyka, listen, this has been a pleasure. It's eight, it's after eight o'clock. After eight o'clock, it went pistol. You just got to fucking plane. No one wanted to do this at this hour.
Are you kidding me? This is so much fun. What I saw you, it was all on. Sean's like, you're like, it's 30 minutes past the ice cream Sunday, right? How far are we past? You're not you're joking, but it's exactly what I'm going to do right now is I know. I'm not a part of what are you have?
What's on your Sunday? What do you put vanilla ice cream chocolate syrup and whipped cream and I do a whole thing of hogging us. No, Jerry, because you start doing two scoops and you're like, well, there's only two scoops left. I might as well just finish you do the, you do the whole pint every single time. And let's see the proof of that. Go ahead, stand up, shake the cookie pouch.
Here it comes. There it is. Good for you. Hey, you know what I'd say? You're enjoying life. Yeah, absolutely right. We all have five minutes. Ty, get your fucking superstar, dude.
Yeah, I love you, dude. I love you guys. Thank you so much, man. Thank you for doing this. Thank you, thank you I love you guys. Thank you so much, man. Thank you for doing this. Thank you, thank you. Yeah, exactly. Thanks for doing it right away.
You asked me if I'd do this about three years ago. I don't know. I'm really happy. I know you did. Listen, for the record, I would have recorded this with you at 9 p.m. Yeah. 10. 10.
I could do better. Well, thank you for eventually doing it. I appreciate it. I'll see you next week. Thank you, Tyka. See you next week. Thanks, guys. Thanks, Tyka.
All right. Thanks, pal. Oh, thank you, Eddie. Well, you pulled it out of your hat there, Willie. I know. Yeah, I know. That was fantastic. So wait, now hang on a second.
That was our first official yawn. I think we've ever had in all of the time. No, you had one during the show that was quiet. It was quiet, yeah, but I hide it behind the microphone so the guest doesn't see it or my co-host don't see it. But we heard that one and so that is, that's an evening record right there with the yawn. Well, it's put it this way. And there's a belch. Good, thank you, Sean. It's 11 minutes after eight and I will be, I'll be asleep by 9.15. Yeah, And I will be, I'll be asleep by 915.
Yeah, I know. Yeah, I'll be asleep by 915. What are you gonna do? What are you gonna do right now, too, you're gonna bed? Right now, I'm gonna go up. I got a kid, the little kids, make sure that they're down. Going to sleep. Yeah.
Okay. I'm gonna go in there and see what's going on on MSNBC. Wonderful. You're gonna make a Sunday. I'm gonna make a Sunday and sit on the couch and get fat. So listen, Tyka, you're going to watch this old house? No, that's Sundays. I watch that Sunday. Yeah, that's Sundays with Sundays.
You don't have a... Do you... Oh, that's so good. I know. Tyka, can I stay down? Scotty! Hey, Tyka, what were you watching tonight? Before we get... well, sorry,
yes, let's get into the tiger. How great is Ty? How funny and cool and radicy. Yeah, it seems very hip and cool and like, you know, he was hard to get on because he kept like, he was changing and then he was like, like two years ago, I was like, hey, will you do it? Like right when he came on my list too. Yeah, and I go Come to the podcast. Yeah, it's a great and then like Trying in this schedule and then he's always in like England and New Zealand and shooting stuff and whatever Me also just doesn't care in the best way No, he does that that sexy indifference, right? It's just like it's like well if it happens it happens if it doesn't it doesn't it's not Atlanta a few months ago this earlier this this year, and I get a text and I said,
listen, you or your doppelganger, or either you or your doppelganger just walked into a restaurant in Atlanta and went upstairs. And then I walked downstairs and there he was on the ground floor with me. Where? In Atlanta. In Atlanta. It's recently? Yeah. was on the ground floor with where? Is it just in Atlanta? In Atlanta. Just recently? Yeah. Well, I know, a few months ago.
He's just such a fucking cool. And that's when he closed the deal for the, uh, Yeah, but that was one of the other times that he was like, yeah, I can't wait to do it. And then he's one of those, but he's one of those people too that kind of created his own style of comedy. Oh my God. Yeah. Yeah, he doesn't have to, Jay, you said he doesn't ask for it.
He's created his own lane. A lane. Yeah, he's created his own lane. And he doesn't, you get this, it's true. You get this, he doesn't really, not that he doesn't care about what other people are doing. It's just that he's into what he's doing in a way,
and he's confident about it. He's super smart and super funny and self-deprecating, and all of those kind of great things. But it seems like he's more concerned in the best way about making himself proud and making himself laugh than other people and other people's opinions or their ability to get what he's doing doesn't really guide what he's doing. No, he's genuinely just literally sent me a text talking. He's a sweet thoughtful person.
Yeah, he seems like that. And you know what, these days, those kind of people, they're hard to come these these days those kind of people they're hard to come BYE WONDERFUL BYE Smart Smart Smartless is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted by Michael Grant Terry, Rob Armjav, and Bennett Barberco.
Our next episode will be out in a week wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen Smart, less. than the holidays. Joyous! Did you say joyous? There is nothing joyous about Christmas. Anyways... I have such great memories with my family decorating, listening to holiday music and watching Christmas movies. Sounds like a lot of noise, noise, noise to me! Oh, hey, well, he's already interrupted my interest so I guess I can reveal our next guest. The Grinch, anything you want to tell our listeners?
Well, yes, actually, I have a new podcast. From Wondery, Tis the Grinch Holiday Talk Show is a pathetic attempt by the people of Rubil to use my situation as a teachable moment. So join me, the Grinch. Listen as I launch a campaign against Christmas gear, grilliesing celebrity guests, like chestnuts on an open fire.
Your family will love the show. As you know, I'm famously great with kids. Follow Tiz the Grinch Holiday Talk Show on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.